[Applause]
wherever you look there seem to be
strong leaders almost normalizing the
notion of strong leadership Trump
affecting to be a strong leadership Xi
Jinping 230 were bond that's where the
gun it's a it's a pretty comprehensive
list and and it's it's curious I find
that at this point in history we should
be again in thrall to big political
personalities instead of policies so
what I'm hoping we will explore in this
discussion is partly why that happened
but whether there are other ways at this
point of approaching and viewing
politics and choosing how were governed
so just yes you're described as a
outspoken Labour MP oh just just in case
you don't know everyone round emitter
professor of politics at Oxford Tanya
Brannigan former correspondent in
Beijing and John am i right who has very
interesting notions of how we might
reorganize politics which we will get to
so yes start off policies or
personalities I think it is I mean
terribly political answer and not very
outspoken I'm afraid to say is that you
need a mixture of both and to me I
suppose looking at the idea of good
leadership it inevitably comes with
reasonable policies that come from the
people they aim to serve or at least it
should to come from the people they aim
to serve my concern at the moment aside
from all of the horrors that you have
just outlined in global leadership is
the idea of strength I mean for a start
off it's an incredibly masculine idea of
strength
I don't recognize Trump to be a strong
man to be perfectly honest I recognize
him to be weak weak willed easily led
and I actually just think his policy is
made up by the last person he spoke to
that day
cariann who sat on yeah it's just like
if you leave the room lust you're the
one who's got the ideas that's the next
executive order so I think that the idea
of strength is is often just about
masculine strength and I don't
particularly think that that is good
leadership the idea that we should vote
for policies now I suppose people also
describe me as being a centrist I am NOT
a centrist I am far more left-wing than
that and also that I'm a moderate I am
NOT a moderate I am a radical in actual
fact it is how I like to view myself but
the idea this sort of centrist idea and
the the macron a sort of style of
leadership or let's say lily through
that's not his name what's his name in
Canada that idea that you are gaining
your insight from the people that you
serve is a style of leadership that I
think is to me much much more appealing
although I think largely is as false as
the strength I don't think that people
just want to vote for policies however I
don't think in fact I've never I not
21,000 doors during the last snap
general election and I met one person
who'd read any manifesto I had didn't
made a single person who actually knew
anything other than the headline
policies of free university fees for
everybody from the Labour Party and
charging you to die from the
Conservative Party which admittedly did
fall down what on one side in favor
hence my majority however maybe you
don't want them to the idea that people
sit and think about policy is for the
birds in my experience of my
constituents actually personality
genuinely matters much much more to the
general public than we give credit for
and therefore I think that really
actually I don't seek a world where
policy is the thing that everybody cares
about okay I just want to see a world
where the people who people follow
aren't so welcome we'll come back to the
question of personality so so
disembodied policies John Doe don't
attract any don't have any traction at
all so the question was should we dream
of a politics where we vote for policies
not individuals yes in short and longer
it's more nuanced of course I think we
should definitely not be thinking that
democracy equals voting for a person and
as much that people are often batshit
crazy it makes very little sense to vote
for a person I think we've just seen
like beauty beautiful examples of that
one one after the other I think we
should be seeking we should be dreaming
of a form of democracy that's deeper
that's more democratic and there wasn't
possible previously so previously it was
only possible to vote for a person or a
party or an ideology or and to go
through hierarchy because pen and paper
was the only technology that we had to
vote so for everyone to go to the ballot
box and vote for something very specific
every two weeks we would require too
many trees it would it would it would be
too too elaborate a process should we
vote for policy I agree I think that's
that's equally absurd like if I was
asked to vote on a very specific policy
every every few weeks I mean I can't see
that I'd find that interesting I'd
rather watch EastEnders then be doing
that which is saying something
but there are other alternatives the
question is not broad enough there are
other alternatives than voting for
individuals or policies and there's
examples of them around the world using
blockchain using AI to genuinely ask
people what their will is and then do
that like that's that's the most
simplest definition of what democracy is
it's asking people what they want as a
future that's not to say what law they
want passed that's a stupid question
asking in or out or left or blues is a
dumb question
but asking what kind of future do you
want and then the role of the leader or
the politician to make that happen
in law in policy is something that I
think for the first time is possible so
it's so the way I see it is that
democracy's been great like it
correlates with every form of progress
you can think of particularly piece but
it's we've been beta testing this idea
for about 150 years not much longer it's
a very new thing and now's the first
time we have the technology to actually
have democracy and so I'd like to see a
conversation that moves like this one
that moves from who's right like who's
correct on because because the question
typically is before asking the question
I have my answer and my answer is an
ideology from the left or the right I'd
like to see us use technology to ask
people what they want and then achieve
and I think that's possible now where it
wasn't it wasn't possible before so we
should be seeking these alternatives
which exists in small small pockets
around the world and yeah well bear with
me because I'm going to talk about a
politics where very few people get to
vote for anything at all I hasten to add
it's not the politics I dream of and
hopefully you don't either but it is
part of Xi Jinping's China dream and I
think it seems to be what a lot of
authoritarian leaders around the world
sort of currently thinking about I mean
Xi Jinping has concentrated power at a
truly astonishing rate at the start of
this process people joked about him
being chairman of everything and now
we're in a position where official media
have referred to him not only as wise
leader but even as my personal favorite
general secretary of people's feelings
it's quite an impressive reach isn't it
so no wonder Trump's feeling a bit
jealous I mean this is really remarkable
because China had prided itself on at
least seeming like a sort of technocracy
it kind of goes back to the 60s and the
age of ideology
Chairman Mao launched the Cultural
Revolution partly from ideological zeal
partly takes extend and shore up his
already incredible power and it was
absolutely devastating it
especially actually to the political
elite so if you look at Xi Jinping's own
history his father was horribly
persecuted his half-sister died he spent
years toiling away in the countryside
this was not an unusual experience and
they were all so scarred that in the
aftermath they decided that they had to
caged power you just couldn't have one
person at the center with this much
Authority so they institutionalized
power they collectivize power they
introduced all these things like
retirement ages and term limits which is
of course the thing that she has just
scrapped for himself there was a vote
within the party which was something
like 3,600 in favor and two very brave
souls against so you've gone from the
age where you had who Jintao the world's
most boring leader probably deliberately
boring and this generation of red
engineers talking about technocracy and
the scientific theory of development to
an era in which you have Xi Jinping
thought which is a body of theory
explicitly identified as being about one
man who's in charge indefinitely now but
I think the really key thing to remember
is that this is not as it's sometimes
being portrayed about Xi Jinping
single-handedly sort of transforming
this system
[Applause]